Hey, this is Presh Talwalkar and you're watching Mind Your Decisions.
It was the problem that left some of the smartest math students in the state stumped and was...
described as one of the hardest problems they ever encountered, reports Pallavi Singhal in The Sydney Morning Herald.
This problem was given to 17 year old students in Australia.
I tried it and honestly, I would not have solved it in an exam.
I benefited from a video explanation by Phillip Liang who was the top student in the state.
I encourage you to check out the video and there's a clickable link in the video description.
So what was the problem in?
Triangle ABC
Point D is chosen on side AB and point E is chosen on side AC
So that DE is parallel to BC and BC
Divided by DE is equal to the square root of two.
The process is repeated two more times.
Point F is chosen on side BC and point G is chosen on side BA
So that FG is parallel to CA and CA divided by FG is equal to the square root of two.
Point H is chosen on side CB and point A is chosen on side CA so that HI is
Parallel to BA and BA divided by HI is equal to the square root of two.
The segment's FG and HI intersect at X,
DE and HI intersect at Yand DE and FG intersect at Z.
There are two parts of this question...
First
Prove that DY is equal to ZE and
Second, find the exact value of the ratio YZ divided by BC
Can you figure it out? Give this problem a try and when you're ready, keep watching the video for a solution.
So let's get started with the diagram. We need to prove that DY is equal to ZE
Now one of the reasons this problem is complicated is because it's a little bit of an alphabet soup.
So one of the benefits of making a video is that I can focus on just the parts that matter for any particular step.
So let's get started by focusing just on these two triangles.
The first thing I will claim is a triangle BFG is similar to triangle BCA.
This is because both triangles share the common angle B.
Their other angles are equal because they are corresponding angles of parallel lines GF || AC.
Next, we have that BC divided by BF is equal to the square root of 2.
This is because the triangles are similar and it's given that AC
divided by GF is equal to the square root of 2
Now we're going to do the same sort of thing with another set of triangles
Here we have the triangle CHI is similar to triangle CBA.
Why is that?
Well, they share a common angle C and the other angles are equal because HI and AB are given to be parallel.
So we now can conclude that BC divided by HC is equal to the square root of 2. That's because the triangles are similar and...
We were given that BA divided by HI is equal to the square root of 2.
So what can we do with this?
Well, we have two different fractions that are equal to the square root of 2, so they must be equal to each other.
Furthermore, their numerators are both BC.
This means their denominators must also be equal. So we have HC is equal to BF.
Now we're going to go back to our original diagram.
The next thing to notice is that this shape, DYHB is a parallelogram.
That's because the opposite sides are given to be parallel from the given information.
We will also have that ZECF is a parallelogram for the same sort of reason.
So now we start out that DY is equal to BH because they're opposite sides of a parallelogram.
Then BH is equal to BC - HC.
We just proved that BF is equal to HC, so this is equal to BC minus BF.
but BC minus BF is equal to FC.
And then FC is equal to ZE because they're opposite sides of a parallelogram.
So we've proven that DY is equal to ZE and we're done with the first part of this question.
Now, let's go to the second part of the question.
We need to find the exact value of the ratio YZ divided by BC.
So on a problem like this, it's not exactly clear how to approach it and how to get to the end result.
So just start out with some information that you do know.
Well, we do know that YZ is equal to DE minus DY minus ZE.
We just proved that DY is equal to ZE so we can then say this is equal to DE minus 2 times ZE.
Next ZE is equal to FC because we have opposite sides of a parallelogram.
We'll then you replace FC with BC minus BF.
We're getting closer to putting everything in terms of BC.
Now recall that BF is equal to BC divided by the square root of 2.
So we can substitute that in now.
All we need to do is put DE in terms of BC.
But that was also given information. DE is equal to BC divided by the square root of 2
So, we now factor out the BC and simplify and we get the following expression.
We then just need to divide both sides by BC so that we get...
YZ divided by BC is equal to 3 minus 2 times the square root of 2 all over the square root of 2.
And that's our answer.
Did you figure it out?
Thanks for watching these videos available for free on YouTube.
Build confidence for students and inspire mathematical discovery for viewers around the world.
They have over a hundred million views and we now have over 1 million subscribers.
Thank you!
Please subscribe for free to get news videos and email me a puzzle or topic at presh [at] mindyourdecisions [dot] com
If you so choose, you can check out my merchandise and my books which are listed in the video description and you can support me on
Patreon for exclusive rewards.
Thanks for watching and thanks for your support.